Gregg over here Jessica what am i
favorite things to do outside of
watching like movie related content is
watching things about disturbing dark
stuff list videos one of the only things
I do that's not movie related content on
this channel 5 disturbing pranks that
went way too far from top five unknowns
I have done some pranks that have gone
too far in my past yeah oh yeah one time
I said my friend died in El Salvador
while he was out there fireworks went
off killed him and his whole family to
everyone at The Improv studio where I
met Monette and everyone else on MySpace
and it did not go down yeah myspace
terrible it is terrible it was funny ten
years ago yeah then it stopped being
funny quickly after I posted that
Alright moan nom on it I'm sorry I
didn't mean to do that
[Music]
I'm glad you're back I'm glad to be back
things for having to provide quality
entertainment for their viewers while
most of the time this works out other
times their attempt is fail epically
fortunately most of these videos are
equally if not more popular than their
videos that worked out well
but these accidents and pranks come at a
high cost whether they severely yeah
yeah you can't go god I think becoming a
much bigger deal oh whether in their
personal lives or a visit to the
neighbor's hospital number five pretty
exciting prank gone wrong
oh no this video was made by the viral
brothers who have become very popular
for playing pranks on each other their
friends and even their significant
others one of the brothers decided to
play an epic prank on the other brother
and secretly filming he made a prop that
looked like he had been cut in half when
the other brother finds him cut in half
in his attic their mutual friends who
was dressed up in a Jason mask holding a
machete her peers in the mask and begins
to chase him but the prank is just a
little too believable the pranked
brother begins to run around the Attic
throwing things at his would-be attacker
when that does not deter Jason the
brother decides to open the attic window
and jump out after he jumps out the
other brother takes off the prop and he
along with our mutual friend go out to
check if he is alright turns out he is
not the brother severely injured his
knee during his fall oh wow
that is hilarious I mean why didn't they
should have stopped him way before that
I mean kudos I mean they didn't know
he's gonna jump out the freakin window
oh you know I guess he would just be
totally terrified oh dude yeah I mean
kudos to that guy for really doing his
best of surviving going [ __ ] it cuz on
any given day he wouldn't have jumped
out that window
but life-or-death I'm gonna great Wow
I can't believe you fell for it Mike
doesn't he know his friends do not do
pranks yeah they should know like look
me that ridiculous I'm gonna jump out
the window oh my gosh that'd be so funny
we should do that Simone nod32 be even
more funny oh my gosh just her injured a
dog no no no she'll forget nope the heat
of the moment she'll forget everything
we said our sporting I can't wait to see
what else is in store goes oh no the
latest YouTube trends is to have a
friend throw fruit at you while you
attempt to cut them with a sword sounds
pretty dangerous right now
well for some it ended quite poorly take
Lance Stewart for example for those of
you who are not familiar with this
youtuber he has quite a penchant for
getting himself injured especially when
it comes to his hands what makes this
particular video pure gold is his
reaction to his injury Lance decided
that one sword was not quite stupid
octina he made it to everything was fine
and dandy until the fourth is missing
but stabs his finger instead Lance
immediately drops the circuit at blood
starts pouring from his hand and he
begins screaming over and over again
that's a participant 1291 one lands
continues to holler and look at the
camera
helplessly after momentarily passing out
he wakes up and starts to roll around as
though it's Monday morning if he's
having a tantrum soon the ambulance
appears and Lance's whisked away
not only did Lance wind up needing
stitches but he had several issues with
his hand afterwards number three
I've got a paper hands before I can
ablate oh my god so stupid my favorite
part of that was I could I could tell
I know youtubers and in this moment
after he cuts his hand and he's standing
directly in front of the camera this
guy's in agony what he knows he knows if
I show my paint in front of the camera
this video is gonna go far feel like too
bad oh man that's funny okay that was
okay we got three more to go three more
to go
cheap prank goes horribly wrong
cheap ranked youtuber San Frisco has his
girlfriend in several of his videos
since he has pranked her in the past one
day she had decided to get even
first she began by ignoring his texts
and phone calls for the entire day so he
would become suspicious and curious as
to her whereabouts with the help of Sam
Fresco's best friends the two arranged
for Stan to show up at his best friend's
house only to have his girlfriend in his
bed everyone expects him to start
yelling and making accusations and he
most certainly does but when he suddenly
gets up and leaves the room his
girlfriend and best friend become
confused
that is until Sam Presti goes up wheeled
in they're gone
then and there would seem like the right
time of telling that it's a prank for
the to carry on for a little while the
best friend attempts to leave the room
and Sam fresco knocks into the ground
that's the wrong with youtubers man they
just try to like keep as much footage as
possible that's just um you can't kill
them
I don't think pranks like that are funny
domestic it's like domestic violence you
never know I would just couldn't do that
to like I would hate if I was dating
someone and she did a joke like that to
me yeah oh this is funny that I made you
believe I was being unfaithful JIT
concern was a horrible man but yeah that
was so stupid like he had a gun
say something immediately yes that was
that was crazy I just thought it's so
funny that they actually told him like
okay maybe now I hope they broke up I
don't know [ __ ] about their relationship
so I need to know I can't date someone
like that there's such a mean frame but
it's funny to watch when people do it
it's funny it's funny to watch but I can
date someone who would do that to me no
we should pull that prank on your
boyfriend no you just hold me in a
chokehold and flex it snap that's your
boyfriend
that's a laboratory rated by blackboxtv
this group of individuals are known for
creating very elaborate pranks and this
one is definitely one of their best the
group asks a friend to do them a favor
by getting into the back of a u-haul
truck to make sure the boxes don't go
tumbling everywhere uh-huh after a few
moments of driving get your truck down
to some train tracks
that the truck has sold out as they
informed the guy in the truck what's
going on they set up speakers outside
the truck that has a recording of an
oncoming train as the guy stuck in the
truck begins to panic the pranksters
tell me that they can't get the truck
door open the to apologize and pretend
to run away as they record the guys
reaction to his imminent death their
friend is angry at first but who can
stay mad over such an ingenious prank -
that is [ __ ] hysterical that's
terrifying
- you're gonna die
yeah I mean when guys do pranks like
that on each other it can be funny
it would just be abusive if they're all
in the truck even like a French Channel
you can't see [ __ ] I mean it's he was
cool about it in the end they said right
he said he was just mad at first I mean
he was like I'm not Ben I mean I don't
know I would I would not be able to talk
to them for at least 24 hours I'll get
fired
I'm pretty sure they all work together
the one else where they have so many
boxes of their shitty than they all were
in uniform ah good good friends guys men
[Laughter]
TGIF bro is a YouTube channel of the two
guys who were always attempt in crazy
stunts and getting themselves injured in
the process these two will do such
things as laying in a bathtub full of
nettles just simply for the experience
of it one of their crazier stunts was to
host their own demented version of the
Ellen
they found an old bathtub and decided
that they should have their own event
with it who can find an open field and
lay down what appears to be a foam core
in a long line using a series of ropes
the to attach the bathtub to a friend's
car oh geez everything was first but
they didn't anticipate the amount of
momentum that they have Wow the tub goes
off the tracks and goes flying sideways
into the field
one of the brothers ends up pretty
injured and had to be taken to the
hospital for stitches yeah what kind of
fun yeah cuz the other ones were like
traumatizing emotional experience what
experience attached a bathtub to a car
yeah that could be fun I didn't say what
they were trying to like emotionally
traumatizing one on that situation I
mean we could have done that yeah I mean
imagine then just driving up to a train
track you know yeah I couldn't we should
find a way to combine all five of these
pranks on no net that would be smart is
she dating anyone people of YouTube okay
what we do is get her to fall in love
with me first okay easy and you're her
best friend she's in love with me and
then work her and I are dating
and then she thinks the you and I are
sleeping together and then on the way
here she survives that comes over here
and this sees you're dead and I was like
I killed her before you could confront
her now I'm gonna kill you ah
terrified Monnet sounds like a great
Christmas for everyone
subscribe to top five unknowns everyone
and make sure to check out Jesse the
Couture dough on the sweet eats YouTube
channel healthy delicious baking with
fun personalities either way you're
looking at pretty girls are you gonna be
satisfied and you can subscribe to the
real rejects take care Japan that's
where most of our subscribers are from
that's funny
arigato mr. Roboto namaste that's what
they say right you don't know what
you're